-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now,
we're gonna get to the news.
According to a new book,
President Biden
proposed to
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
five times before she
agreed to marry him.
So basically, he proposed
marriage the same way
that he ran for President.
"How about now?
Okay, how about now?"
A growing number
of top Russian officials
are reportedly
starting to question
President Vladimir Putin's
invasion of Ukraine.
Which means there's about to be
a shrinking number
of Russian officials.
[ Laughter ]
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
criticized Disney yesterday
for opposing Florida's
so-called "Don't Say Gay" bill,
and questioned
what kind of content
the company will now produce,
adding,
"In every episode now,
they're gonna have
Mickey and Pluto going at it."
What are you talking about?
In every episode?
You have to build up
to something like that.
That's season finale stuff.
The FBI recently arrested a man
for participating in
the Capitol attack
after he was turned in by
the driver of the Uber he took
after the insurrection.
Well, that'll teach him him
to give 3-star rating.
[ Laughter ]
"Politico" this week published
its first election forecast
for the 2022 midterm cycle.
Not to be outdone,
Fox New already called it.
[ Laughter ]
The fast food chain Popeye's
announced plans yesterday
to launch a flagship
in Times Square.
Man, I miss the gritty days
of this city,
when the only place to eat
in Times Square
was the Olive Garden.
[ Laughter ]
And unnamed worker has filed
a labor complaint
that alleges Nintendo violated
their right to unionize.
Well, it wouldn't be
the first time they tried
to sow discord by pitting
tradesmen against each other.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
the legalization of marijuana
lowers the demand for
prescription medication.
I mean, sure, why go
all the way to Duane Reade
when you can just go
to Dwayne?
[ Laughter ]
And finally -- thank you to
my drug dealer, Dwayne,
for letting me use this picture,
by the way.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I guess that's
one of the nice things
about, you know, the
decriminalization of it all.
Two years ago, he'd be like,
"No, man."
And now he's like, "No, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know, you can
put my number up, too."
And finally,
in a new interview,
the co-founder of
Arizona Beverages said that
the brand's popular iced tea
will remain priced at 99 cents,
despite inflation,
which sounds amazing
until you see how much they've
shrunk their iced cans.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!